ont lancé des briques c'est devant une
piscine du quartier saint-roch à québec
que la 15e brigade splash a été lancé la
tournée estivale permettra comme à
l'habitude de sensibiliser les baigneurs
de former les sauveteurs et les
gestionnaires d'installations aquatique
mais cette année les gens devront être
plus alertes surtout que dans certaines
régions du québec
on peine à recruter des sauveteurs et
des milliers de cours de natation n'ont
pas eu lieu en raison de la pandémie
les enfants n'ont pas suivi de cours de
natation depuis des kansas derniers mois
on prétend qu'ils sont ils deviennent
plus à risque justement d'être victime
de noyade de l'eau toute l'importance de
pouvoir dire autant au moniteur de camps
d'été de quinze jours quand vous
fréquenter des lieux de baignade vous
avez un rôle et un mandat de
responsables type surveiller
selon la société de sauvetage 28
personnes se sont noyées depuis le début
de l'année au québec comparativement à
32 à pareille date l'an dernier
voyez qu on y sent jouer dans les moules
dans les mêmes ou en termes de nombre et
c'est pour ça qu'on fait cet appel à la
prudence et la tragique noyade d'un
enfant de dix ans à la base de plein air
de sainte-foy la semaine dernière est un
triste rappel en ce début d'été
il participait à une sortie scolaire le
gouvernement attend le rapport du
coroner pour déterminer si le port du
gilet de sauvetage devrait être
obligatoire dans de telles circonstances
on va regarder qu'est ce qui va se
passer au niveau de l' enquête
mais dites vous que dans tous les
ministères impliqués
on a pris ça très très au sérieux on
étudie la situation on va attendre quand
même le rapport nankin en attendant
sylvie bernier une ancienne plomb jeux
olympiques qui a elle même perdu son
neveu par noyade lance un appel pour
rattraper le temps perdu quant aux cours
de natation
on se rend compte qu'il ya à peine 50%
des enfants qui savent nager
on sait tous se baigner les deux puis
vraiment qui touche le fond d'eux les
psem et la minute de nos enfants perdent
pied ou tombe de façon inattendue le sur
le bout des seins qui chaque fois nargis
l'an dernier 95 décès liés à l'eau sont
survenus au québec
du jamais vu en dix ans ici quand les
côtés paulette radio canada québec